es gibt so ein cooles spiel da kann man
beispielsweise einfach eingeben hey was
wäre wenn angela merkel donald trump
wäre
und dann bekommt man eine mischung von
baaders wer hat ekelhaft auf jeden fall
spielen wir das heute ich würde sagen
wir geben mal direkt das ein was sich
bereits zu beginn gesagt habe und zwar
what if angela merkel was donald trump
noch ein fragezeichen hinter dann
schicken wir das ganze mal ab und jetzt
sehen wir eine mischung aus angela
merkel und donald trump
das sieht aus wie ein richtig herzliches
baby what if angela merkel was george
bush gebe ich jetzt mal als nächstes ein
die nachricht ist abgesendet das heißt
wir bekommen als nächstes wieder dienen
ja ja ja gerade nord und südkorea so ein
bisschen frieden strip sind würde ich
sagen als nächstes what if angela merkel
was kim jong-un fragezeichen
mal schauen ich will ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht wissen ich habe noch nicht
hingeguckt meine damen und herren ich
mir das jetzt nämlich zusammen mit euch
tun und zwar in 321 das ist
oh mein gott
liegt das nur an
la merkel dass das alles so komisch
aussieht welche personen ist ähnlich
machtvoll wie angela merkel
naja stimmt von crafter wolf kim jong-un
meine damen und herren geben weil das
ganze doch einfach mal einer bin ich
jetzt echt gespannt also wie würde ich
als kim jong-un aussehen als er quasi
macht herrscher von nordkorea das
das sieht überhaupt nicht creepy aus vor
allem habe ich gerade macht herrscher
gesagt ich glaube nicht dass das wort
existiert ich war ja auch auf dem echo
meine damen und herren und habe
natürlich auch mitbekommen wie kollegah
und farid ihren echo gewonnen haben und
wie das ganze sehr sehr umstritten war
mit der rede von campino noch ich habe
auch die schlägerei mitbekommen ich
stand täglich drei meter daneben das
heißt what if kollegah und farid bang
wie würden die zusammen aussehen
listig gibt die sachen da immer ein und
ich merke schon beim abschicken
das wird jetzt echt crazy
das
sieht schon wieder eigentlich aus wie
ein hässliches baby farid bang ist ein
bisschen kleiner er südländischer
herkunft ich bin ein bisschen größer ich
komme aus deutschland ich habe blonde
haare farid bang hat schwarze haare
kurze haare
ich glaube unterschiedlicher können zwei
menschen nicht sein deswegen schauen wir
jetzt mal wie es aussehen würde wenn ich
war ebay wäre also ich habe jetzt
einfach mal gesagt wurde kontrabass
farid el abgelaufenen eine bizeps ist
breiter als freunde es lustig an dem
spiel ist dass wir es auch umdrehen
können das heißt wir sehen nicht nur wie
ich in dem körper vom verein bang
aussehen würde sondern wir können auch
sehen die farid bang in meinem körper
aussehen würde und davor ekel ich mich
gerade so ein bisschen also worte farid
el abdellaoues kongo
farid bang
dass mein körper aber meine damen und
herren meine lieblings youtuber dann
habe ich ja noch gar nicht erwähnt in
diesem video und zwar natürlich katja
glaser witz was wäre wenn ich kann ja
casa witz wäre
ja eindeutig ich kann nicht katja
coverbild sein ich hätte mir das ganze
eher so vorgestellt aber okay what if
katja krasa will swisscom crafter habe
ich jetzt einfach mal eingegeben
da bin ich jetzt sehr sehr doll gespannt
weil hier das ja vorher nicht geklappt
aber wir sehen schon das nächste
warum sieht alles hässlich aus wenn es
auf mir ist
bitte nicht antworten allerdings ist
katja glaser witz ja nicht mal eine
einzige lieblings youtuber dann sondern
ich habe ja noch babys beauty palace
also von crafter was babys beauty palace
ich habe schon lange nicht mehr auf
videos von der reagiert hätte ich aber
auf jeden fall mal wieder bock drauf
wir sehen jetzt dass foto a
das sieht gar nicht mehr so scheiße aus
und was ist wenn baby ich wäre
wow
great pixel
ich finde hat so todes geil dieses spiel
freuen denn was kann man noch eingeben
elf babys babys im babys beauty palace
sowas katja krawitz kann mir auch mal
machen das ist jetzt quasi eine
kombination meiner beiden lieblings
youtube drin da freue ich mich ganz
besonders drauf ein paar sekunden später
was das spiel hat sich gedacht hey wenn
wir katja glaser witz und bewies beauty
palace zusammen packten das geht nicht
das wäre zu krass da zeigen wir lieber
nur den körper aber schöne beine
an der stelle wird das heutige video sei
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn es wie sie zeige ich auf
meine couch wenn es euch gefallen hat
und ihr sagt hey luca das ist megageil
macht das doch eventuell nochmal mit dem
youtuber und der person und blablabla
dann schreibt mir das und in die
kommentare welche person ich das nächste
mal fusionieren soll und schaffen wir
6000 likes ist ultra ultra viel freude
aber wenn ihr mehr von diesem format
sehen wollt dann lasst diese anzahl da
ich jetzt mega bock darauf und jetzt
sage ich einfach nur noch